wir kommen jetzt zu meinen fünf tipps
und tatsächlich wirklich eine brisante
entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshof alle menschen die bei den
plattformen parship und elitepartner zu
viel geld bezahlt haben bekommen jetzt
ihr geld teilweise zurück und darum geht
es in meinen fünf tipps waren sekunde
beide partner oder parship dann haben
sie hier eine gute möglichkeit geld
zurückzubekommen
tipp 1 vollziehen sie nach wann sie
gekündigt haben vielleicht nach einem
tag oder nach zehn tagen
tipp 2 wie lange liegt das zurück was
innerhalb der letzten drei jahre dann
haben sie wirklich gute chancen geld
zurückzubekommen fordern sie zu viel
bezahltes geld innerhalb von 14 tagen an
das ist ganz wichtig setzen sie in der
knallharte frist und da gibt es auch
e-mail-adressen tipp 4
die e mail adressen sind kundenservice
at parship de oder kundenservice
elitepartner.de schreiben sie dorthin
und die firmen wollen natürlich auch
jeden einzelfall überprüfen und sie
haben da tatsächlich sehr sehr gute
chancen
verzichten sie deswegen am besten auf
eine klage die ist teuer und zieht sich
möglicherweise lange hin warten sie erst
mal ab und regeln sie das thema erst mal
so
[Musik]